[Music]
got something
looks like we lost him
dr aldeway you have a patient who goes
by the name of dylan forrester he's one
of my most interesting most promising
patients
when was the last time you spoke has he
done something then you mean attempted
murder then yeah well that's progress
is there anything you need to tell me
no you're not the same man you used to
be deep dee's younger brother professor
sean forrester is dead the funeral is
today you got a lot of nerve coming here
get me someone in the washington state
police
the fbi he broke his ball short of him
[Music]
fbi not exactly research the house first
and found out no one dies until we find
out what they know
i'm trying to do my best here
don't be too hard on yourself
oh sure and i'll shoot you both
so now do you understand what happens
when you don't help me jacob
find me a way back in
what aren't you telling me
sean must have told you what's here on
the island
you're being shot at
oh yeah
do whatever it takes to save your enemy
did you really kill people uncle
they were really bad people
[Music]
you